hello freak [ __ ] you don't have to
watch your weight length this [ __ ]
ridiculously addictive in some [ __ ] up
way is million dollar listing ever watch
that show you know what it is so yeah
he's gay guy yeah houses yes my wife
watches that show with that [ __ ] the
gay guy lives in Connecticut so you lose
like a so yeah ridiculous okay he looks
like he's like claymation he doesn't
look like a real person
it is so white I am the number one real
estate agent in all of New York I like
putting my best I love that guy and I
already start speaking out what did you
speak Swedish yes and I don't know where
he is no that's not the guy that's not
here not him
no that's that's the one from neat no
that's the other one the one of the
right on the right you got the right guy
that [ __ ] guy areas are the one of
the loop middle looks a lot like I'm God
that's weird
they all they're all have on lipstick
they look exactly the same
million dollar listing that's Los
Angeles that's a different one yeah the
one in New York the [ __ ] Solaris
[ __ ] Jay dude I love that guy so the
guy in the middle is there I haven't
seen that guy before I've always seen
the one in New York with the male model
in the middle there's a middle one of
the right is an angry psycho like me the
dude in the middle is sort of a middle
ground and then the other guy is like I
mean he's right out of Hogan's Heroes it
was a house that they were selling in
Los Angeles that was on that show and I
was watching it and they were trying to
sell it for twenty million dollars and
it was for sale recently stood as
actually a house it's really for sale
but it's like right above Sunset Strip
like you could see it from the strip
like you imagine about a twenty million
dollar house and you can just look at it
like you can look into the windows I
mean it's a half a block above the trip
you're looking out your window look at
CBS is across the street no yeah that's
what I just thought you were but is like
that I mean on this it's on right there
it's not above it it's here's the strip
here's Sunset Strip here's the first
couple of buildings it's right there
I mean it's [ __ ] right there it's
true they wanted twenty million dollars
from and the listings usually that those
are cause like the last episode I
watched is like the the gay Gestapo guy
is sitting there going
he walks in to this lady and he just
goes okay here's the offer
the final offer they could give you is
eleven point three million dollars and
then she just another one she read on
the right I told you no negotiating he
waste my [ __ ] time let alone he's
just sitting there going oh my god oh my
god yeah you know and I was I was
surprised he took that level of [ __ ]
iwase would be like lady is not my fault
you think it's worth fifteen million
dollars to [ __ ] lunatic I can't do it
so he just sits there listened and then
she leaves and I'm like holy [ __ ] they
finally didn't sell a house and then
just boom two seconds later somebody
calls up after he does the whole she
walked out the door it was like winter
in Russia right and he [ __ ] all of a
sudden somebody calls up out of nowhere
it just goes all right eleven six final
offer that's it and then he calls the
lady up and then she's all just like see
that's all I wanted yeah that's exactly
once
yeah and I wanted I got a balance that
was too easy and there's the handsome
model who just takes a shirt off all the
time he's ripped that guy with the the
Josh fellow with the line my wife likes
him of course she does yeah let me like
him guys shredded yeah okay I don't get
bad a beautiful man she could literally
be like I'm leaving you for him and I'd
be like I I guess that I get it I see it
you gotta do what you gotta do
good good for you man congratulations
Michael there you go hey at least we had
a kid together
did we hug you know Matt let's go back
to taking Todd did he - I figured you
know he's a better-looking dad he's
probably better at than me
you
[Applause]
[Music]